P Diddy allegedly assaulted his sons
football coach with kettlebells and I
guess you guys are friends but you
immediately went on insta you went on
Instagram with this really funny did did
he find that amusing
it was funny to me because like no
matter what you do you get these
different status like you'd be like
write or produce a mogul yeah and soon
as you get in trouble to go rapper I saw
that happen to him and I was like
laughing I poked fun at it because you
know it didn't seem like a real serious
thing there wasn't it kind of you know
starts bad no matter what it is it
starts bad and the news and then it kind
of makes his way over to something
positive yeah yeah and and no one
reports it when he starts to become
positive right and and then as I started
to you know work his way out you know I
felt better about me poking fun it went
through a period every thought should I
done that and then later on you thought
that's pretty funny yeah hey thanks for
watching be sure to click subscribe to
see even more great conan clips you may
now return to your pirated movies and
creepy japanese pornography